guys i'm confused third function
diverter
rear remote grapple-ready okay these are
common terms that kind of all apply
to the same type of remote that we're
going to talk about today
that's where the confusion lies right
there's so many names there's very
little standardization i'm going to give
you my take on it
it might not be your take but it's how
i'm going to explain it to you if we
have a conversation
i did a video recently about 15
attachments for a third function
several of the comments in that video
said i got it wrong and what a third
function is
and that's what i want to discuss today
is how do we interpret a third function
is there a standardized system or do we
kind of have to read between the lines
maybe visually see the machine that
we're looking to buy figure out what we
need to set up our equipment
and the position of it on the front in
the middle or the back
does any of it really even matter i'd
love to get your feedback so leave a
comment down below we can all help each
other and learn a little bit more
the goal is to get smarter every day so
if you like what you see here i'd love
to get a thumbs up
and make sure you hit that subscribe
button right down below if you haven't
done so already
and as always read through the
description underneath the video
all sorts of helpful links right down
there for cool tractor products or head
on over to goodworxtractors.com
all right let's get to it
let's dissect this a little bit we are
talking about a function all right not
the third it could be the first
second the fourth to fifth but a
function in general on a hydraulic
system
could be called a circuit as well pretty
much any modern air attractor that has a
front-end loader is going to have
two hydraulic circuits so you'll have
two hoses down here with
corresponding outlets that are on your
machine that is going to be one
hydraulic circuit it allows the flow to
go this way and maybe raise your loader
up
and then it allows the flow to come back
through the other hose the other
direction so that you can
lower your loader as well now if we work
our way up this next set of hoses is
going to be the second
function or the second hydraulic circuit
so if the flow goes
through the hose this way it's going to
allow you to curl the bucket back
if the flow comes back this direction
it's going to allow you to dump the
bucket now what you see here on top
is going to be that additional function
or this additional hydraulic circuit
so what that allows you to do is
maintain the first two circuits
add on a third function so if you have a
grapple connected to your front end
loader
not only can you raise and lower you can
curl and roll
you can also open and close and again
that's controlled by hydraulic flow
going
one direction or another direction
through those hoses so two hoses
kind of makes a circle or a loop and
allows that functionality to be complete
that circuit to be complete going both
directions so now that we have a basic
understanding of what a third hydraulic
circuit is let's explain the different
variations of what that is
primarily a third function versus a
diverter kit they're going to both give
you a
additional hydraulic circuit that third
circuit that you need to run something
like a grapple
however they're going to function
differently let's dive into that now now
i don't want you to pay too much
attention to the location
of these hoses the location of these
couplers the location of this third
circuit more importantly i want you to
understand that what's found on my 4066r
for example is going to be a third
function control
so this is a factory option you can get
after-market third functions as well
but this is going to be plumbed into
your traktor's hydraulic system in a way
that allows you to control not just the
first
and the second but the first second and
third hydraulic functions
all at the exact same time so you can
run hydraulic flow from your tractor
through all of those hoses all three of
those circuits
to raise and lower at the same time as
you curl and roll
and at the same time as you open and
close the grapple for example third
functions can be used for other
attachments
i'm not focusing on that we're just
focusing on functionality
now the other primary variation of that
third hydraulic circuit is known as a
diverter kit or a diverter valve so
instead of being able to use the first
circuit that second circuit
and the third circuit at the same time
you're going to t
in to those hoses into the fittings that
are part of that curl roll
function so you're going to tap into
that second hydraulic circuit
you're going to put in a diverter hence
the name which is essentially going to
have
a solenoid or a little valve on it so
it's going to send a
a signal to the solenoid solenoid
chris gives me garbage for that all the
time the point being you're going to get
an electrical circuit it's going to
divert the flow from your
curl roll function and as long as you
have that
redirection going on it's going to send
that hydraulic flow to
your third circuit to instead of curling
and rolling
you can then open and close so you are
diverting the flow from that second curl
roll function
to the third function of opening and
closing the grapple so as you can see
a diverter kit is a way to get that
third additional that third
hydraulic circuit however you just can't
use all
three circuits at the same time okay so
if you've made it this far
let's see if this next part confuses you
is a third function
and a rear remote the same thing
well i'm going to make the case that it
does not matter if it's on the front or
the back of your tractor
now before we get to that i need to
explain what we have going on here
because
if three functions just isn't enough for
you well get yourself 10 functions like
what i have right here
it might be a little bit overkill but i
want to go through it really quick
because
it gets kind of confusing and
intimidating now we're not going to
count the two functions that are up
front for the front end loader besides
that there's eight additional hydraulic
circuits that we could have back here
so right here you're gonna have your
third function these lines are actually
plumbed up with some soft hoses
going all the way up front to run the
grapple then you're gonna have
a fourth function down here and then
we've sacrificed our fifth function
and plugged it into this hydraulic
multiplier you see up top
this is going to give us six additional
functions you can see there's a couple
extra
circuits here or functions that are not
being used right now but we have the
ability to do so
if we should ever need it remember just
like the third function
you need two quick couplers to complete
a hydraulic circuit
or a function whether it's the third
fourth fifth sixth seventh eighth
ninth or tenth i don't want you to think
that you can run ten hydraulic circuits
at one time because
compact tractors simply can't do that
there's not that much hydraulic capacity
or flow rate to do so
and in fact controlling just two
functions like raising and lowering
and maybe curling and rolling at the
same time can be challenging enough
even for a semi experienced operator
like myself
trying to throw on a third function such
as opening and closing a grapple
while controlling those other two i'm
not very good at that
but just because you can't use six or
seven at the same time
doesn't mean that you don't need to have
six or seven or eight
circuits hooked up in my case and i'll
give you the quick rundown as i have it
set up right now
i have eight total functions connected
right now the first function will raise
and lower the front end loader
the second function will curl and roll a
bucket or a grapple in this case
the third function is going to open and
close the jaws of the grapple now the
fourth and the fifth are going to
control the top and tilt kit that i have
while the sixth seventh and eighth
function are going to control
the hydraulic chute rotation the
hydraulic deflector and the hydraulic
back drag
now fortunately i don't have to use all
of those circuits at the same time
because i don't have enough arms and i
don't have enough brain power
most of these functions here are just
momentary knees but nobody wants to be
hopping on and off a tractor connecting
or disconnecting hoses
from one circuit to another circuit and
vice versa every time you need to do it
very inefficient so to control that big
shiny multiplier back there
i simply use this little switch panel
right here to select the circuit i want
to turn on
flip that button and then actuate it
with a lever
and then turn it back off so if you're
looking for an affordable way to add on
additional hydraulic capability to your
tractor
you need to check out these hydraulic
multipliers from summit hydraulics now
if this wasn't sweet enough by itself
it gets even sweeter when you can get
five percent off with code gwt
at summit hydraulics so a couple folks
took issue with a statement
or a general theme of a recent video i
did on 15 attachments that proved the
value
of the third function because i included
attachments that were mounted on the
back side of a tractor
not just mounted to your loader it was
their interpretation that a third
function
was ran right up front and something
connected up there
and operated that way nothing to do with
the back side if you have this
additional function on the back side of
your tractor
that's called a rear remote and so
that's why this is so confusing because
this john deere 4066r
i purchased it with a rear remote and a
third function which are the same exact
thing and in fact even inside the cab
right underneath the third function
control which is just a push button
right on my loader joystick
it's got a little roman numeral for
three right and when i received this
tractor
that third function terminated on the
back side of the machine right back here
it did not have these hoses plugged into
it and running up front
that's something i added on after the
fact but it was identified by john deere
as a third function
and the outlets terminated on the back
side of the tractor so if you're new to
the tractor world
welcome to the confusion you know i
think you just need to have a good
understanding of what that third
function capability can do
and realize there's a way to route that
functionality
towards the front of the tractor or on
the back side
but having that additional hydraulic
circuit that's the important part
so similar to the factory third function
that's on the 4066r
a diverter kit that's giving you that
third function or that third
circuit could be mounted up front it
could also be mounted on the back side
the tractor does not care either way
because wherever you need
that additional hydraulic circuit you're
going to care about that so if you have
something mounted on the back side of
your tractor like a snow blower
that needs to have a hydraulic shoot
rotation that's where you want the third
function
or if you need it mounted up front to
have that third circuit up here
to control the grapple that's important
to you as the operator but a third
function in my opinion can be mounted on
the front can be mounted on the back
it doesn't really matter so part of a
diverter kit besides the hoses and the
solenoid and the lines that go up front
or maybe to the back is going to be
a new joystick that you get to control
that entire operation
so this new joystick is going to include
controls to operate that third function
or
in this case a diverter kit let's talk
about price you know you want to get
that additional hydraulic circuit on
your tractor on the front or the back
but you don't want to spend a lot of
money well a diverter kit might be the
way to go
typically you're going to spend 500 or
600 bucks maybe somewhere in that
ballpark to get a diverter kit
and get that additional circuit mounted
on your tractor however if you want to
get a factory third function like what
you see on my 4066r
you could spend possibly 2 000 maybe
even 2 500
if you get those grapple lines that run
all the way up front as well
so if you want to get the functionality
of the third circuit but you don't want
to spend thousands of dollars
on completing that process maybe a
summit diverter kit
could be the solution for you and like
that hydraulic multiplier you can get
five percent off with code gwt
you just go to summit hydraulics.com
there's a link right down below
do some shopping on there find the right
kit for you we've done a video on how to
install this kit we've also done a field
video of this as well so you can see it
in action out there picking up brush and
logs and other debris
with the work saver mini grapple this is
a really great combination for a
subcompact or smaller compacts as well
so my interpretation if i'm listing a
tractor for sale having a conversation
with the customer
i'm going to identify if it's a diverter
or if it's a third function i'm going to
let them know
but that does not mean that it's ran all
the way up front and
ready to plumb in a grapple right at the
end of the loader arms but if you do
have hoses or lines ran all the way up
front to the very
business end of your front end loader i
am going to go a step further and call
that grapple-ready
because you don't have to invest the
cost to run lines from the back of the
tractor all the way up front okay or
from the midpoint all the way up front
you already have those lines there so
that's an extra cost that you don't have
to consider or worry about it's already
done
but if your third function your third
circuit your diverter
terminates on the back side of your
tractor all you need to do is just get
some soft hoses made up
plug them in back there route them all
the way up front to your loader
and you're ready to go the important
part is having that third
circuit on your tractor so maybe that
helps you maybe it doesn't
but for me when i'm looking for tractors
because that's what i do i buy used
tractors and i resell them
if i see something has that third
additional circuit whether it's a true
factory third function or a diverter kit
to me
in my opinion having that third circuit
of some kind
on your tractor that's the valuable part
that's going to open up the versatility
and make it more appealing to future
customers like yourself and really the
other big takeaway for me
is the fact that with compact tractors
in general they have a pretty limited
flow rate
for hydraulics so it's really
challenging to run
three functions at one time let alone
two functions at one time because
there's simply not the hydraulic flow
and the mental capacity at least for me
to operate all those smoothly and
succinctly so investing that money into
a cheaper diverter kit
still allows me to get the job done but
at a lower cost
so i've given you my interpretation of
what a third function is
but now it's time to hear yours so leave
a comment right down below
and as always if you like this video i'd
love to get a thumbs up from you
make sure you hit that subscribe button
right down below if you haven't done so
already
and read through the description as well
all sorts of helpful links down there
for cool tractor products or head on
over to goodworkstractors.com
thanks so much for taking the time to
stop by until next time stay safe
we'll see you soon
[Music]
you